I have a story for you that unfortunately
you won't understand unless you understand something about Kurds.
I mentioned earlier in the show that Donald Trump yesterday had one of the strangest
press conference that I've ever seen.
And I was watching it, initially as I was working on a bunch of other stuff for the show,
And at a certain point I just had to stop focus exclusively on the press conference
because it was so insane. And at a certain point during this press conference Donald Trump takes a question
from a Kurdish journalist named Rahim Rashidi, who works for Kurdistan TV.
And Trump calls on the guy as "Mr. Kurd", ok? Now this might not be immediately
jarring to you - although I know that to many people in the audience it will be - what you have
to understand to really understand the context here is that Kurds are an ethnic group, right
so "Kurd" is interchangeable in terms of like a category item with something like "black"
or "Jewish"  for example.
So when Trump calls on someone by saying "Mr. Kurd" it's the same as if a black journalist
stood up and raised their hand and Trump says "Go ahead Mr. Black"
or a Jewish journalist stands up and [Trump] says "Next question Mr. Jew".
That is the equivalent of what Donald Trump is doing in this.
Check out this very very short but extraordinarily bizarre video.
TRUMP: Yes please, Mr. Kurd
*Crowd murmurs with some laughter*
TRUMP: Go ahead.
JOURNALIST: Thank you very much for your time Mr. President
This is the sort of intangible debasement of the culture around the office of the presidency
that goes well beyond policy. It doesn't have to do with Trump's misunderstanding of trade deals
and his destructive tax plans and his  complete lack of knowledge of how money works;
this is kind of like the flavour and character of this administration's effect making of the United States
just look really stupid around the world. And the problem is that Trump and his followers are too ignorant to realise
how sort of mindblowingly horrible this is. People will write to me - you know they will Pat - and they'll say
"David you're too sensitive it was a term of endearment" or something like that.
You would only think that if you both have: number one no idea what Kurdish means,
and number two no understanding that this is the same as Trump calling on other reporters
by their race or ethnicity. And going back to my example where I said this would be like saying to a black reporter
"Next question black guy". Imagine for a second if Barack Obama during one of these press conference
- just like really think about it ok? - Obama goes up there maybe he's just had some kind of fancy mustard
maybe he's wearing a tanned suit, so people are already enraged about what he's doing,
and he calls on a reporter by saying "Mr. white guy, next question please".
Trump did almost exactly that here.
PAT:  Yeah and of course I don't think Trump would say "Go ahead Mr. black guy"
DAVID: Of course not.
PAT: or "Go ahead Mr. Jew".
But he doesn't understand like the historical context and why you can't say that.
DAVID: He doesn't get that it's the same thing.
Right exactly, he doesn't realise that Kurd as a characteristic is equivalent to
someone who is ethnically Jewish or someone who's black.
And by the way Trump has a moment of almost the doing exact same thing but with a black guy.
Remember this absolutely ludicrous moment from a Trump presidential rally during the campaign?
TRUMP: We had a case where we had an African American guy who was a fan of mine
DAVID: Shocking.
TRUMP: Great fan. Great guy! In fact I wanna find out what's going on with him.
You know what - Oh! Look at my African American over here, look at him.
*David chuckles*
Are you the greatest? You know what I'm talking about? Ok.
So we have an African American guy at one of the rallies a month ago. And he's sitting there behaving.
*David laughs*
And we had protestors inside the arena.
DAVID: This is like, Trump doing an impression doing an impression of the Trump
of the Trump you would expect to see on Saturday Night Live, right.
And I was thinking as I watched the clip this morning preparing for the story,
we're almost like numb to this, right. Like if it had even been George W. Bush who had faux pa
after faux pa, and horrible display of ignorance after horrible and embarrassing display of ignorance,
time after time after time as president.
If it was even Bush we would be reacting more strongly. But this is politics under Trump.
"Mr. Kurd go ahead", "There's my African American", there was a black guy who was behaving at a rally, go figure.
PAT: This is the kind of thing that your slightly racist Uncle says at a dinner party,
DAVID: Yes.
PAT: and you family's all kind of used to it and you kind of give him the pass. But we shouldn't give
the same pass to the President of the United States.
DAVID: In the same way that we shouldn't give the - it's all about context and that's why you know
with the Brett Kavanaugh stuff, not to go back to it I feel like we've covered it enough, it's not just
can this person be - I don't even want to insult anybody's job - but it's not can this be some low level
entry level thing - uh - job somewhere.
This is the an appointment for live to the highest court in the land, it's one of the positions of greatest power
and responsibility in the United States period, right. And the expectation should be higher.
The idea that "you know listen... it's like yeah there's multiple accusers but it was a while ago
and we kinda have a schedule to get to here and we wanna have the vote on Friday", we would be reacting
way more strongly to what Trump is doing if we weren't completely desensitised to it.
We would be, hopefully, reacting way more strongly - or many of us are reacting strongly but others are not -
to the allegations against Brett Kavanaugh if we hadn't elected a president who had 16 allegations against him!
Right so this is all - these are horrible horrible realities that we're dealing with, but you can just tell
that so much of the population has become numb to this stuff and that's really disturbing.